how long you've been doing the podcast
for
uh 20 25 minutes
this episode yeah how many how many
episodes uh are you cool
since april we just started but i'm i'm
so thrilled that you're here i wanted to
you you
we'll talk more about the movie and
things like that but you alluded to
something and if you don't want to talk
about it that's okay but i'm happy to
talk about whatever my man okay because
i'm a a proponent of
you know mental health sure and uh you
know i talk about my own struggles
you just talked about getting clean bam
yeah i worry about that guy that you go
that guy
is you're not in touch with him right
now are you
no absolutely i mean i've been in such
very close contact with him
uh that it's crazy it's just it's it's a
difficult situation
what is the situation is it a mental
health is it substance abuse
is it what is it he's got
well-documented issues with substance
abuse and i think that there's another
layer
uh of mental health you know it's sort
of each exacerbating the other
you know like these issues are
compounding and what is it
i know that when i got sober i was
diagnosed as bipolar
and i was given all kinds of bipolar
medications
and um you know fortunately over the
course of the
subsequent years it all kind of mellowed
out
and i'm hopeful that that would be the
case for bam if he were to uh
really address the chemical dependency
so he hasn't addressed that yet so he's
still in a dangerous
uh he's uh i think that things have come
to a head as of late
and well i just know that
that uh you know there's been some
activity i think he actually might
like be as we speak
uh getting into a treatment center
i i i can't confirm this i don't know
but i know that's
the last time you spoke to him um the
last time i spoke with bam
was via text message about a week or two
ago and he's been uh
the the last couple weeks have been
particularly colorful for him
colorful like in sort of a you know
there's been
escapades and the intervention like uh
traveled he's a wall he's you know
that intervention is it a forced
intervention where there's been many of
them
yeah but in the last week there was one
and then yeah there was there was a
another one in the last week and you
feel like he's in a place right now
where he's on the right track
ah i think that he as i said things have
come to a head
and i do believe that um that the latest
concerted effort to intervene um
is uh has been a
sort of focused on creating a
sort of a legal layer to it which would
require
uh you know a certain amount of
treatment
are there good is he surrounded by good
people who can take was his parents like
i mean there's been a great deal of
enabling
that's gone well that's that's usually
the problem with with everybody so
what i'm saying is do you feel like he's
surrounded by the right people who can
send them in the right direction
i've been in super close contact with
with this family with his wife with his
mom
um and i gotta say that after
such years of just feeling like you know
i wanted to just
grab them by the shoulders shake them
like you're da
you know like guy contributing to the
problem
and really i feel like they're actually
they've come to a place where
they're they're they're kind of
understanding like oh you know
what about the fact that he wasn't in
this latest movie is that i mean that
one uh
i think that everything that we've seen
in the media
uh regarding bam and his exclusion from
the movie
which by the way he's the only person to
announce that
you know like that was and and people
who watch the movie will
be able to tell he's not well they will
but everything that we've seen in the
media
with regards to that has sort of
demonstrated why he couldn't be in the
movie
if if that makes any sense the way that
he's been conducting himself
sort of precluded his involvement so
that's what people don't realize and
that's why i
love i love you and i love the movies is
because
you know for the most part you make it
look like just a bunch of guys
chaotically making their way through but
what people don't know it's a whole
production
and a lot of money goes into it and it's
all really planned
and uh executed you know in a way where
it's
it's it's a real business it is
and thank you for the kind words and
also i think that
um it's jackass
as a franchise i mean it's it's it's
changed so much over the years
in the beginning it quite literally was
just
us running around with video cameras and
and
beginning at a time where we weren't
even really
cognizant of release forms and such you
know like
we went from just a shoestring like just
guys with cameras we would laugh and
then we got it and
over the years it's become like a bigger
thing you know like
productions got bigger budgets got
bigger like
everything got slower you know you would
think that being on the set of a jaguars
movie was just
like crazy funny but it's actually so
just painfully slow
absolutely what people don't realize is
even if those things happened
right by happenstance there's no way to
ensure that they're going to be captured
so the plan has to be this is going to
happen here i'm going to run over here
i'm going to do that i'm going to need a
camera here you're going to have to
slide you better grab it from this
angle and many angles so that right
because i'm not going to do this a
hundred times
there are certain things that are one
and done and there are a lot of things
that
like the directors just you got to do it
again and it's like oh but even
one and done right would take hours to
set it up absolutely